على وقع الخطوات التركيه نحو التطبيع مع
دمشق وصل وزير الخارجيه الايراني حسين
امير عبد اللهيان الى انقره للبحث عن موطئ
قدم لبلاده في مسار التطبيع الجديد
التصريحات الرسميه بين مسؤولي البلدين لم
تخرج عن مالوف الدبلوماسيه من ترحيب
بالجهود الساعيه لتقريب وجهات النظر بين
تركيا والنظام
السوريع ورئيس الجمهوريه اكد على هذا
الموقف ولتحقق هذه الخطوط نتائج واضحه
سنكون على تواصل مع ايران
وتغير شكل العلاقات بين الدولتين نحن
ممتنون جدا من وصول العلاقات الى هذا
المستوى ندعم ونؤمن باي خطوه ايجابيه بين
الدولتين
خفايا الاجتماعات وفق ما نقلت مصادر من
انقره ابرزت رغبه ايرانيه في دور محوريه
بواسطه بين الاتراك ونظام الاسد موازن
للدوري الروسي وذلك قبل توجه وزير
الخارجيه التركي الى واشنطن لنقل هذا
الملف الى طاوله المسؤولين الامريكيين
الرافدين للتقارب مع الاسد لكن دوره طيران
المنشود يراه اخرون انه بعيد المنال حاليا
امام وساطه روسيه قويه نجحت في عقد لقاء
ثلاثي على مستوى وزراء الدفاع
للحوار التركي السوري ولكن هناك دور روسي
ابراس وهناك وساطه روسيه همم
تحقيق هذا الاجتماع الوزاري بالبساطه
الروسيه وفي موسكو ويسود اعتقاده الاوساط
السياسيه التركيه
ان طهران لعبت دورا في تاخير اجتماع وزراء
خارجيه تركيا وروسيا وسوريا حيث كان من
المنتظر ان يعقد في النصف الثاني من يناير
الجاري لكن الاجتماع تاجل ولم تسر عجله
التطبيع وفق الاهواء التركيه يرى متابعون
لمسار التطبيع مع دمشق ان انقره ستحاوله
على الاقل خلال الفتره الحاليه تجنب
الاستعانه بواسطه جديد طالما ان الوساطه
الروسيه ما زالت تؤتي ثمارها وتقبل تركيا
لدور ايراني لن يكون الا في حال تعثرت
موسكو بالوصول الى اختراقات تمنح انقره
مكاسبه سريعه قبل الانتخابات زيدان زينجو
العربيه اسطنبول